have you guys ever been to the uh i know
it's a proper like tourist trap or
whatever it's considered by the the
golden guy in shinjuku
oh yeah i've been enough did you like it
no no
no not your thing not really gonna
explain what golden guy is yeah so
golden guy is like this
[ __ ] what is like 40 by 40 meters area
if you will and it's just like a series
of alleyways extremely compact it's not
even a block
it's like it's within the block isn't it
yeah it's tiny and these bars
all seat max three to four people
sometimes two yeah um
depending on where you go and uh it's
really expensive uh you pay like
sometimes like a ten bucks just to sit
down and then you only pay like ten
bucks for a drink
um and yeah it's a tourist trap because
a lot of the time it's tourists and also
it's a very sketchy area
yeah and if you are a foreigner there
will be a guy who
is very much watching you yeah the
moment they see your foreign they'll
come up to you
it's really [ __ ] frustrating yeah i
went in there once
uh just because i wanted to take my
friend who would never yeah so i was
like okay i'll experience it and yeah i
was just like man this is just like a
really
cramped super expensive drinking
experience that you can get
anywhere else it's like if you see
pictures of it which will probably
be on screen now it's it's kind of like
cyberpunk house cloud
i love going to golden gate just to take
photos yeah it's it's
like that cyberpunk aesthetic where you
just got these all
a lot of these buildings and a lot of
these bars just like cramped together
and you don't even know how anyone could
live in there let alone operate a
business in here
because i can't imagine any of these
bars getting maybe more than like
10 people across like a night right uh
it depends there's one or two of the
bars that are decently big
but most of them are yeah like i mean
there's like a few big ones like outside
of golden gate like right before you
enter it they're like near the entrance
but like when
once you actually go into golden gai
it's like how do any of these places
stay open
i think it's you i think you go to
golden gai
to meet other people right you don't go
there with your
well you can go there with your members
you can also meet other people anywhere
else
but there's this kind of vibe to it
that's like because it's so small
right like you immediately have to talk
to anyone who's next to you yeah like
you don't really have a choice
like in the rest of tokyo you kind of go
out your way and be like
hi you want to know about my cult right
like you've got like really you've got
to pray
yeah yeah you've got to seem like a
little weird right but in this bar
you know you sit down you're immediately
next to someone and you just start
trying to communicate
and uh yeah the one time i went was
because um
i was staying right next to it funny
enough and i think it was one night
where
uh it's my second to last night in japan
my first time visiting
i think joey joey like gone and allen
didn't want to hang out and i was like
well i want to do something so
i googled i'm like where can i go and
then this was the only place that came
up and i was like
fine i've never heard of it before i
didn't know it was a tourist trap yeah
so i just went there
and uh yeah it was really fun i mean met
a ton of people and then
eventually made friends with these like
japanese people who took me to someone
like the japanese only bars
yeah and that was really fun because
then they were all talking to me asking
what my favorite anime was
knowing the japanese titles came in very
handy that day oh yeah of course
yeah it's just a lot of fun i mean when
it works and you go out and you meet
people and they're actually cool and
it's fun it's like
the best thing ever i feel like you got
a quite a lucky experience though
especially in golden gai because i think
so yeah i've heard a lot of like horror
stories about goals
i think a lot you could easily go there
and just have not mean anything for the
worst time
and yet spend a lot of money because
i've been to like quite a few
like smaller bars and establishments
that are outside like just outside of
that
guy this is really [ __ ] cool uh
gaming bar that chris broad took me to
yeah like
literally across the row from golden guy
yeah one apple
zero i think it's called one up yeah
i've been there yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it's tiny like
there's just one bar it can only maybe
seat like you know six people
yeah but like it's like a proper game
but we're not talking about the one that
you guys looking to do
okay right it's like a legit like gaming
bar and that one was really [ __ ] cool
and way way cheaper than golden guy but
the problem is is that those kinds of
places don't come up in
google searches right it's almost always
like where do you drink and change
golden guy always comes together yeah i
noticed there's like a lot of bars in
japan that are [ __ ] tiny and you go
in there
and it's like i really like the vibe
because it's like a really intimate vibe
because it can only fit like
five to six people and there's only like
one bar and you see at the counter
um but i do like that vibe and i don't
know how they stay in business
because there are so many in japan and
they're so hidden away
yeah they're so like the cigar bar we
went to in ikabuka
it was like how the [ __ ] would anyone be
like yes let me go into this tiny
building go all the way up to the sixth
floor
and there it is right there it's like
how would you how would you know that
that's
yeah yeah right it's it's like it could
be just someone's apartment before we
know it probably is something
that they just remodeled that's kind of
like the size we're talking about yeah
uh like like an apartment in tokyo just
yeah like a one-room apartment yeah
yeah well you jumped to that bar that
was like it was like an apartment
someone's apartment in an apartment
building that had been converted into a
penguin oh yeah
yeah and i was like what the [ __ ] is
this and yeah they've said food and
everything it was [ __ ] weird so that
sydney actually discovered that because
she read a manga that i was based on
like a manga that had that bar and she
googled and that bar actually existed so
it's this
it's this ping pong bar that has like
this massive ping pong table in the
middle it's like going into someone's
living room
to get there like we had to go down the
dodgiest alleyway right it was literally
this
handwritten sign that says ping pong bar
go down this alleyway and so we go down
this alleyway it's like a dirt it's like
some [ __ ] from pt
yeah like there could be someone doing
heroin around the corner you had no
[ __ ] clue
uh so we go in there and then we had to
go up these stairs and it was just like
the
stone stairs that someone's probably
pissed on you know
yeah so we go up and then it's just
someone's apartment it's just literally
someone's apartment
but you but then they you know they open
the door and it's like a proper they've
properly remodeled it into a bar
and i'm thinking man how would anyone
[ __ ] discover this because this is
just
hidden away down two [ __ ] dodgy
alleys that i would not
go down that's what i'm saying it's like
there are so many where i'm just like
you wouldn't if you didn't have a
curious mind and you weren't afraid that
you might possibly get stabbed down this
alleyway
there are so many places where it's just
like you'd never be able to see it i
mean
yeah that's why i think shinjuku's good
especially if you're a foreigner because
you can
i think a lot of people in shinjuku are
like wanting to meet foreigners and
stuff like that or shibuya
so if you stay to those two places yeah
they're super touristy and everyone
knows about them
but i think a lot of places outside of
that you probably won't find people who
are super eager to talk to foreigners
maybe
maybe maybe yeah but that's as far as
you'll probably go right yeah i mean
in shinjuku you'll definitely find
people who want to speak to you if
you're a foreigner oh yeah and then
like sometimes you go to a bar and like
the people serving you
have to have to speak to you as well
yeah that's fun yeah i like that
experience like the
one place we went to that started
playing all of our youtube videos
so there was this bar that we went to
right there was this bar that we went to
like a really small internet bar
um and they've i can't remember who
brought up the conversation but i
remember
they found out that sydney was a
youtuber because sydney was there as
well right
and she makes the stupid mistake of
telling her her youtube channel
so this bar has like four like has like
about
three tvs in it right and so
as soon as the bard lady hears her
youtube channel she just like chromecast
sydney's [ __ ] cities videos
i've seen this video all over the bar
where like other people are also
drinking there
so we're just there watching silly's
youtube
and she's she's just like dying inside
that's a [ __ ] nightmare isn't it
that's the one thing you shouldn't do
if you have a youtuber friend is play
their videos in front of them oh yeah
exactly what is it about that i've never
understood something just hearing your
own voice or
you being not like being silly right
yeah yeah but it's just like it's like
you're okay with you
it's such a weird dilemma because my
cousin asked me that same question where
she's like okay
so you're all fine with me watching your
videos as long as you're not there
but the moment you're there you don't
want me watching the video like how does
that make sense i'm just like
i don't know i just don't like it